- My fucking dad's an asshole, right?
'Cause financially we're broke right?
So he's like holding
financial power over us.
What can I do?
My mom's the only kind of--
- You've gotta break out of that pattern,
you've gotta not listen
to him and make money
in however way you want!
Listen, otherwise you're stuck.
If you wanna help your mom,
sometimes the best way to
help your mom is to get out
and then come back and get her out.
- I'm only 14, I can't do shit!
- I get it.
So honestly, honestly, and I respect that,
listen to me.
Life is long.
You're in a shit spot right now,
by my mom didn't have
her mom or dad at 14.
Life is long.
It sucks shit right now.
When your 14, it feels like
it's your life forever.
It's not your life forever bro!
You understand?
Surround yourself with as much positivity
to get you through this shit chapter.
- I just can't fucking do that shit.
I have no fucking friends.
- I get it bro.
Bro, you've gotta be patient.
It's early.
- I know it's not fucking forever man,
I can't take this shit!
- I get it, but you have to understand
there's no alternative.
There's only two choices here:
You stay under that roof and eat shit
for four more years, three
more years, two more years;
or you bounce now.
Plenty of fucking people bounced at 14.
It's not common in the
UK but people do it.
Or you don't.
Life's about a very simple fucking option.
You either do it or you don't.
If you're gonna fucking
eat shit under that roof,
you need to put your fucking ear pods in
and listen to positivity 24/7
to get you through that shit.
Do you understand?
When your surroundings are shit,
you're inside's gotta be positive!
The fact that you're even here
means you're fucking halfway home.
- All right, thanks man.
- You're welcome.
I wish you well man.
Hit me up anytime, DM me all right?
All right?
You listening?
Listen to me, listen to me.
When it's shit around you
you have to make it positive in your head.
I know it feels like it's fucking forever
and it's gonna take forever.
When your 14 four more years
sounds like fucking forever,
but you have no choice.
You either bounce or you stay.
And if you stay, which is
more likely, which is fine,
you gotta put fucking
positivity in your ears.
Do you understand?
I promise you, you have
no other alternatives.
Otherwise you just dwell
and you go down a spiral
that you don't wanna go down.
You understand?